Okay, so we can do A and B.
So, let's pick another function.
What's your other favorite,
Boolean function of two variables?
>> Well, if we're doing two attributes,
you know, or
is the other really nice one.
>> I like or.
So, let's see.
Do you think, now that we've shown that
we can do A and B, could we do A or B?
>> I feel like we could do A or B.
because there's that nice De Morgen's
Law relationship between them but but
let's just, how about this,
can you erase the tags at the bottom?
>> Like that?
>> Oh, yeah but
that's not going to work, is it?
So, so if B and A are both true, so
the left branch, then the,
the, the leaf should be plus?
>> Yes.
And if B is true and
A is false then the tag should be plus.
>> Yes.
>> And if B is false, I want to say
false but we don't know because A could
be true and A or B is true if
either of the two of them are true.
>> Oh okay, so
maybe the mistake here is just trying
to use exactly the same thing.
So let's just erase it.
>> All right.
>> And start from scratch.
So what would you do
starting from scratch?
>> I'd split on B again.
>> Okay.
>> True False or False True.
>> True False.
>> All right, and now if B is true.
We know that A or B is true, so
we can put a plus under the left side.
>> Right.
>> But if B is false.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then we need to split on A.
>> Okay.
>> And if A is true, then we're golden,
we get the Or is true.
And if A is false, then it is false.
>> Very good, and
that represents A or B.
>> That represents the function,
the logical function A or B, yeah.
>> Right.
What happens if I swap A and
B around, does it still work?
>> I mean, my, my, since they're
collaborative or commutative.
Since they're commutative I want to say
it shouldn't make a difference, but
let's just double check that.
So if A is true then the output's true.
If A is false and
B is true then the output's true.
And if A and B are both false,
then the answer's false, yeah, totally.
>> Excellent.
And, you know, if I hadn't erased
it you would see that the two trees
actually look very, very much alike.
>> They're sort of mirror each,
of each other.
>> If you just swapped around.
Yeah the, yeah exactly,
they're mirrors of one another.